El Salvador is a small country.
In fact, it’s the smallest country in Central
America.
But, that’s only geographically.
The country has 6.5 million inhabitants, a
population that’s larger than Panama, Costa
Rica, Belize or Nicaragua.
That’s a large population, especially when
you consider that emigration from the country
is common.
According to various sources, some 3 to 4
million Salvadorans are living abroad, with
many living in the US...
Shhh, don’t tell Trump!
Emigration is ever popular with thousands
of Salvadorans each year packing up their
suitcases and take a chance on a better future
somewhere else.
If this rate of emigration from El Salvador
maintains, there might soon be more Salvadorans
living outside Salvador than living inside
it!
So now, you are probably wondering why so
many people are leaving El Salvador (or not,
I mean we had to title this video something!).
But let have a look at why so many people
are leaving this country.
Yes, it is true that El Salvador is a very
poor country, but economics is not the only
reason people are leaving.
Now, before we get into details on what’s
causing this exodus, let me give you a quick
bit of information:
El Salvador is a tropical country where you
can find stunning beaches like these, as well
as magnificent nature reserves like this one,
and amazing cultural remains.
And in 2017 this country is celebrating.
2017 is the 25th anniversary of the Peace
Agreements which put an end to the bitter
and cruel civil war which last more than 12
years and caused more than 70,000 deaths.
The
conflict was between the national armed forces
and the so-called Farabundo Martí National
Liberation Front, a left-wing paramilitary
guerrilla group which counted on the support
of the Cuban Government.
Interestingly, after the peace agreements,
this guerrilla group became a political party
and today they have the Presidency of the
Republic…
Quite the remarkable change.
Now, while this 25th anniversary should be
reason for celebration, it is hard to celebrate
when you look at the current situation that
El Salvador finds itself in.
THE VIOLENCE
The 11th January 2017, was a normal Wednesday
when something extraordinary happened: absolutely
NOTHING…
So, let me explain, that day ended with a
death toll of zero in El Salvador.
And yes, that non-event was actually front-page
news.
The reason for this being newsworthy is that
El Salvador has become one of the most dangerous
countries in the world.
To give you an idea of how dire the situation
is:
In 2015 6,670 murders were registered.
That is to say there were 105 murders for
every 100,000 inhabitants.
This is the highest rate any country in the
world which is not at war.
This number is truly terrifying.
For comparison, it would be as if there were
70,000 murders in the UK a year...
The real figure for the UK?
A touch more than 500.
That’s 140 TIMES MORE MURDER!
In 2016, the number was a bit lower, but still
almost 4000 murders were registered.
It’s madness.
There have been wars where less people died!
Oh, and believe me, murder is far from the
only serious crime going down in El Salvador:
kidnapping, extortion, thefts…
all worryingly common.
So, who's up for a holiday to El Salvador?!
No?
No-one?!
Considering all of this it’s probably not
so surprising that according to recent surveys
conducted of the population that nearly half
of them want to leave the country!
It’s clear to see that violence has consequences.
And this is not just fear of a crime being
committed directly against you, but it also
affects the standard of living of the El Salvadorians.
According to the Salvadoran Central Bank,
violence costs around $4 billion every year.
And, you know what?
That’s not really very suprising.
After all, who really wants to invest his
money in a country where you can be killed
any time.
Don't believe me?
“El Salvador's foreign investment is the
lowest in of all Central America”
Even regular people are at risk in El Salvador.
In fact the statistics show that it is more
dangerous to be a bus driver than it is to
be a police officer in the country.
In the last 5 years, street gangs have killed
almost 700 bus drivers.
VIOLENCE IN THE REGION
It is known globally that Latin America has
a serious problem with violence and crime.
According to a report from the British consulting
firm Verisk Maplecroft, Latin America is the
region where you have the highest risk of
having a violent crime committed against you.
Indeed, 6 of the world's 10 most violent countries
are in this region.
Incredibly, 1 in 3 homicides that occur every
year globally take place in Latin America.
Even in this dangerous environment, the northern
triangle of Central America takes the biscuit.
This area is formed of El Salvador, Honduras
and Guatemala, and it is, by far, the most
dangerous area in the continent.
In fact it is the most dangerous region of
the world that is not currently a war zone.
In these countries, which are relatively small,
200,000 people have been murdered since 2004.
When you think about the reality of these
numbers, it’s understandable why people
want to leave a country where you can’t
walk the streets at night safely, or wear
a watch or necklace, or start a business without
having to pay some money to a criminal organisation.
So the question must now be: Why is there
quite so much violence?
DRUG-TRAFFICKING AND “MARAS”
However, these three countries in Central
America have not always been such dangerous
places.
They could even have been considered relatively
peaceful until about 20 years ago - at least
at the individual level.
But this all started to change by the end
of the 80s and 90s for two reasons: drug-trafficking
and Maras.
First: drug-trafficking is a serious problem
in the region.
Every year, 22 million Americans use drugs
and most of them come from South America.
The drug cartels are making an absolute fortune
from this.
Obviously, this isn't something new, but this
activity has evolved over the years, and has
continually found ways to operate despite
pressure from law enforcement.
The persecution of the famous Colombian drug
cartels led the the route drugs take to the
US shifting from: Colombia-Caribbean Islands-Florida,
to a new route going through Central America,
and this is our first big problem.
Central America has become a sort of sanctuary
for the new Mexican drug cartels.
From Central America they can organize their
businesses, hide drugs and take refuge from
justice whenever needed.
So you’re probably starting to get the idea.
Experts have calculated that 80% of the drugs
used in the US goes through Honduras.
And this has lead to an extraordinary amount
of violence in the region.
Now to our second major problem.
The “Maras”.
For those of you who don't know them, the
“Maras” are street gangs that engage in
all kinds of criminal activities like theft,
murder, or extortion.
Their members are usually young people and
their organization is relatively horizontal,
meaning they don’t have much of an organised
hierarchy.
They organize in criminal cells known a “clicas”,
which work quite independently from one another.
Pay attention here because it is estimated
that in these three countries alone, the “maras”
have around 70,000 to 100,000 members.
The most famous of these organizations are
“Salvatrucha” and “Barrio 18”, and
both usually fight against each other over
the control of different territories.
THE FIGHT AGAINST VIOLENCE
The situation is complex.
Many strategies have been used to try and
solve the problem and they have all failed.
However, two initiatives have been put into
practice lately in order to change the reality
of these countries and achieve safety for
the citizens.
The first is known as “Fuerza de Tarea Trinacional”
(the Trinational Task Force): This is a security
apparatus formed by police officers, intelligence
experts, and special units of the three countries
we have mentioned.
This group aims to fight the street gangs,
drug-trafficking and organized crime regardless
of borders.
Also, the group receives the support, training,
and finance from the United States.
The idea is clear: as Juan Orlando Hernandez,
the President of Honduras, likes to say:
“We are going to give them a taste of their
own medicine".
The second initiative is linked to the first
and it is known as the "Alliance for Prosperity"
and it was launched by the Obama Administration
and it expects to improve the living conditions
and the competitiveness of these countries.
Its main goal is to create jobs and essential
infrastructure in order to reverse the terrible
current situation.
To start, Washington has already committed
to spend $750 million to support these initiatives.
But, is there hope?
Well, there sort of has to be.
Mara Salvatrucha has already communicated
they are willing to negotiate their own dismantling.
Only time will tell if any of this is successful.
So that’s our view on the region, but what
do you think?
Will these countries get rid of criminals?
Will the plan set by Washington succeed?
I´m looking forward to your answers and with
the growth of this channel we can’t respond
to them all, but know that we do read them!
As always, hit like if you enjoyed the video
and don’t forget to subscribe for new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
And as always, I’ll see you next time.